Một mỗi tháng 1 theo dưới phương, tổng thống lâm thời vỷ đi dưới la,
đean si, vô juu ghê, tuyên bố, thả rời khá sáng đáng người mới tới miếng,
tham gia một chiến trình hợp tác, trong khun khổ lật pháp của tế,
bà rô juu ghê, người được bạn, tối cao vỷ đi dưới la bộ nhẹp làm lãnh đạo lâm thời,
sau khi tổng thống Nicolas Maduro bị Mỹ bắt giữa, nhấn mạnh rằng,
hoa bình toàn công chỉ có thể đa đuận, khi chủ quyền và anh đing của mỗi cua sai đu vào đam.
Theo bà, vỷ đi dưới la ưu tiên thí là quán hệ của tế cần bằng không cần thiệp và dự chinh bình đảng dưới các khu sai.
Chông thông nghiệp người Washington, lãnh đạo lâm thời vỷ đi dưới la,
chị tiếp theo cầu chiến quyền Mỹ đối thoại và hợp tác, nhằm hướng tới phát triển chung và trung sống hoa bình.
Bà cũng cho sang người dân vỷ đi dưới dưới la và khu vực này sứng đáng được hưởng hoa bình lâu sai.
Cung ngày, tổng thống Mỹ đôi đôi đôi đôi xam đưa xa tuyên bộ kinh sẵn,
thành bà ông bà road you get sẽ phải đúng mặt với các hợp quán nghiêm chọng, nếu không hành động đúng đánh,
thầm chiến nặng nè hơn, tổng thống Nicholas Maduro, nơi đáng bị nghĩ thạm giám tại nhà tuy như do.
Ông cũng để ngọt khá năng tý tụm một đột tấn công quân sự lần thứ hai và video dừa là nhằm vào chính quyền Caracas.